Lo segundo era pedir perdón.
Tuve que pedirle perdón a la gente que había dañado.
Aunque no tenía expectativas de que lo aceptaran,
era importante hacerlo porque era lo correcto.
Pero también tuve que pedirme perdón a mí mismo.
Lo tercero era el resarcimiento.
Para mí, eso significaba
volver a mi comunidad
a trabajar con jóvenes en riesgo
que iban por el mismo camino,
pero también reconciliarme conmigo mismo.
Con la experiencia de estar encerrado,
una de las cosas que descubrí es esta:
la mayoría de los hombres y mujeres
que están en la cárcel son recuperables.
Y el hecho es
que el 90 % de los hombres y mujeres que están en la cárcel
en algún momento regresarán a la sociedad
y somos responsables en determinar
qué clase de hombres y mujeres vuelven a la sociedad.
Hoy mi deseo es
que tengamos
una actitud más empática
hacia el modo en que manejamos el encarcelamiento masivo,
que nos deshagamos
de esa mentalidad de "encerrarlos y tirar la llave",
porque está comprobado que no funciona.
El mío es un recorrido singular,
pero no tiene que ser de ese modo.
Cualquiera puede transformarse
si generamos el espacio para que eso suceda.
Lo que les estoy pidiendo hoy
es que imaginen un mundo
en el que hombres y mujeres
no sean condenados por sus pasados,
en el que los delitos y los errores
no determinen el resto de una vida.
Yo pienso que juntos podemos hacerlo realidad.
Espero que Uds. también.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)